we need to talk do we what do we need to
talk about my darling maybe about the
fact that my favorite character on
Empire just got shot last week right
looks like a fatal shot to me but then
you had to go off on Twitter and write
this really somber message about saying
what a great time you've had on the show
just true I have be honest you're just
messing with us aren't you i Wednesday
at 9:00 8:00 central only on Fox
no we ain't done come back here come
back here so what can we expect from the
season finale it's really going to be
wrapped up and it's handled in a
beautiful way and you know it's all love
and it's you know it's it's I think that
there's gonna be some tears but there's
also going to be a lot of a lot of a lot
of happiness so you know it's it's it's
it's okay it's gonna be great it's it's
a phenomenal finale phenomenal and all
questions will be answered Wednesday at
9:00 8:00 central only on Fox I lose you
I'm throwing a fake visit Lee has been
getting death threats of people being
like if Jamal dies you die knife emoji
knife emotion knife emoji so yo the fans
are on another level it's incredible but
you know we'll we'll have to wait and
we'll have to see I wish it was lucious
to his shot thank you so much